what's up everyone bang bang there's
brand new report out from the white
house talking about proof of work and
bitcoin mining in the report they
basically took a look at after an
executive order a study on how exactly
proof of work mining and the electrical
consumption could have an impact on a
bunch of their different goals and
initiatives what we see from the white
house is they are putting a very big
focus on things like climate change and
of course that brings up the
conversation of bitcoin mining in the
report they say that bitcoin mining and
proof of work has negative impacts that
it could have a lot of electrical
consumption and that there's a lot of
stuff that we still don't understand
they even go ahead and put estimations
sometimes as much as a one percent of
the global electrical consumption on the
proof-of-work mining industry but as
we've seen time and time again this is a
lot of talk but there isn't yet any
action what we have seen is that other
countries they have looked at electrical
consumption and they've decided to ban
proof of work take china back in 2021
what happened is that proof of work
mining just moved to another location
and that's exactly what i think would
happen here if the united states decided
to be adversarial towards proof-of-work
mining now in the report they aren't
necessarily taking a position where they
say this is bad and we must get rid of
it instead what they do is they try to
have a well-rounded conversation on one
part they say look this actually could
help stabilize the grid this could help
with a number of different
climate-related issues that we're trying
to address but they also have a part
which a lot of bitcoiners have focused
in on where they say if we cannot
actually have a positive impact with
this technology congress should look at
potential legislation to ban
proof-of-work mining now of course as
with many things this is a study and it
could be positive it could be negative
there's a lot of attention on it but it
doesn't necessarily tell me any one
thing in terms of what they're going to
do and so my guess is that the industry
will continue to evolve it will continue
to grow investors will continue to pour
capital in to profitable business in
many cases it's the most profitable use
of energy that anyone could have and so
as we've seen in the united states where
we went from less than five percent of
global hash rate within the country to
now close to 40
i think that we will see an acceleration
of proof of work mining now one thing
that we do need to make sure that we're
paying attention to though is there is
the door open for an adversarial
position against group mining and that's
where education becomes really important
what i have seen is even people who are
esg investors the more they learn about
bitcoin the more they learn about how
proof of work actually is used they
become bigger and bigger proponents of
bitcoin it's similar to nuclear power
many people it's scary at first they
don't know that much as they get more
educated they say wow that sounds like
something that we should probably be
leaning into i think that's what's going
to happen with bitcoin here and so it's
important that the education efforts
both of the energy companies of
politicians and just generally of market
commentators the more we can educate
them the more likely they are to see the
benefits the more they see the benefits
the more that they will become
proponents and therefore the
conversation will change so we got a lot
of work ahead of us but i think that
this report while there are some
concerning parts is actually pretty
bullish because what it is explains is
that the white house sees there are some
potential positive impacts of proof of
work and bitcoin mining hopefully the
positives will outweigh the negatives in
their mind and they will continue to
embrace this technology the united
states needs to be a leader here it's
one of the fastest growing economic
sectors and it would be a shame for us
to push all of this innovation all of
these jobs and its economic progress
outside of the united states so let's
keep an eye on this no actionable things
at the moment there are some negative uh
potential consequences in there but i do
think that right now where they came out
was actually pretty rational and so
hopefully we'll just do more education
we'll get them to lean into more and
more the positive aspects and everything
will be good i hope this helps you
understand exactly what happened in that
white house report and i'll talk to you
guys next time hey you did you like this
video great make sure you subscribe like
the video and see you next time